it's too dangerous I need to go alone
we're all in this to the end
we've got friends out there good people
will fight if we leave them they've
taken enough of us now we take the war
to them
let the final battle
again Star Wars the rise of Skywalker
video pg-13 get tickets now
let the final battle begin
we won't surrender we make our last
stand
star wars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
please pass Town Hall me now the
thousand generations live in you now
this is your side
on December 20th
this saga
we'll end
[Applause]
[Music]
let us find all that or
with you
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now fine now
they fly now
[ __ ] fear
the destiny of a Jedi
your destiny
[Music]
it's okay that we're here it's okay that
you're here's good to see you that to us
our Wars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
this will be the final word
in the story of Skywalker
[Music]
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now and fronting fear if the
destiny of a Jedi your destiny
[Music]
if this mission fails it was all for
nothing
we're not on home good people will fight
if we leave them
[Music]
we got you that you yes it's it
starwars the rise of Skywalker tickets
available now
oh we've done all this time we're doing
there are three bill taking one last
look sir at my friend
confronting fear
is the destiny of the Jedi
your destiny
we're all in this
[Music]
command Star Wars the rise of Skywalker
I think it's available now
you